-[ Chuckling ]
-Hi.
-I'm Ron.
-That's the only
living footage of Ron.
♪♪♪♪
Well, you have to remember
that you get hired,
and there's not a lot
of hand-holding here.
And then I remember
having moments
of, like,
"No one thinks I'm funny.
This is gonna be rough."
I was always kind of awestruck
at how serious
the place can be at times.
And I thought, "Wait.
This is a comedy show.
We should be
[bleep] [bleep] up."
And so I would sometimes
sit in this writers room
as Chip Kudrow,
Lisa Kudrow's brother.
Or maybe I'd just put on glasses
or something.
Steve Higgins would be like,
"Can I help you?"
I'm like,
"Yeah, I'm Chip Kudrow."
[ Laughing ]
"Lisa Kudrow's brother."
"Oh."
"Yeah, I'm guest-writing.
Lorne didn't tell you?
Anyway..."
They would
actually go through
the normal constructive proces
of giving notes,
and then Steve would go,
"Chip, any ideas?"
And I'd just be like,
"This one's good to go."
We did a lot of stuff waitin
for Lorne at the read-through.
One time, I organized that w
all, like, when Lorne walks in
just go, "Surprise!"
And then, of course,
Lorne was like, "Are we done
Okay. Open on..."
[ Laughs ]
There was a sketch --
We were doing, like, a
"Smokey and the Bandit" parody
So I'm in these Wrangler jeans
a Western shirt,
one of those sleeveless fleece
jackets, and a trucker hat
For some reason, we had
to tape it throughout the day,
so I just stayed in my costume
the whole day.
And then I wore the costum
the next day.
There's this writer, Tom Gianas,
who's like,
"Please wear the costume
for the rest of the year."
And that was like November
So I wore it every day
for the rest of the year.
I think sometime in the spring
Alec Baldwin was hosting.
And he came up to me, he's like,
"Is that how you
normally dress?"
I go, "Oh, no, this is a bit
This is a yearlong bit
I'm doing."
"Okay, good, because
it's not a good look for you."
"Okay. Thank you
for telling me, Alec."
Then there was this characte
Ron that I came up with
with a fake mustache
and an ascot
and this weird outfit
that I found at a thrift store
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Hi.
-I'm Ron.
-I never broke character.
I just went, "I'm Ron."
[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah, this is Paula Pell.
-What do you do
here on the show, Ron?
-I'm working for Jim Signorelli.
-Oh, I forgot. I worked for Jim.
-I'm his nanny.
But I also work
second camera unit.
-And, yeah, I just started
showing up as Ron,
who was really annoying.
-Ron, what are you doing?
-Having a snack.
-There was one moment wher
we were in this writers room
watching Puff Daddy rehearse
and someone said,
"Ron should go up onstage.
And before everyone
turned to see,
I had sprinted out the door.
It's supposed to be
a closed set.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is when Ron
is just appearing
on the stage with Puff Daddy
I didn't really know what to d
once I got up there.
Oh, then I -- then we
shook hands. That was good
-Hey, Ron? What'd you thin
about Puff?
-I'm not familiar --
He seemed fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
If you go back and look
at the good-nights of that show,
Ron might be in the good-nights.
I just have a feeling.
-Puff Daddy, John Goodman,
Paula Abdul, my man, Nick Lea.
Happy Mother's Day!
-Because of the nature
of the show,
the kind of day-to-day pressures
of having to produce materia
and things like that, so I was
always trying to find ways
to make everyone remember
that we were all
on "Saturday Night Live."
You know, this is supposed to be
a really fun job.
[ Chuckles ]